yeah there we go uh we're good okay
we're going to win this one
we're going to this is really weird
so magnus is playing okay so pawn pawn
we're going to go with pawn here okay uh
bishop very surprising andrea
not another london uh you know what i
love doing this is one of my techniques
bishop okay good isn't it actually
copycat
i will just give you some subtle hint
when they start
[ __ ] up and we should not mirror them
anymore
let's
[Applause]
that was a terrible move i didn't mean
to do that you didn't even say bishop
whoa
okay so they're throwing for content as
well effectively he's lying to us
he doesn't even know london theory yeah
yeah now
we're in in tight waters magnus i'm not
as comfortable in this
in this position another pawn move so
i'm just gonna have to trust your
your instincts no i'm a magician so
whatever
whatever piece you say i turn it into
gold just
think of it like just think of it that
way last time right yeah yeah okay
that's nice
sounds great for me uh and andrea i'm
not i'm like a budget magician
sometimes i make it happen other times
the chat sees the tricks
you're a magician you make your queen
magically disappear every game
exactly exactly
i might think that this is time for
a pawn move okay sure
okay
well that was a nice
pawn move we kept pushing the wrong he
turned it into gold now i don't know he
did i don't know
okay i think it's enough to uh it's big
enough to call an animation
what is this no it's it's the best move
it's the best move
oh oh thank you magnus i thought we were
giving a pawn but i just realized i had
a
brain fart the rook is defended
so alex here is a little london lesson
so you know when i said pawn three moves
in a row
it was so that when they did this we
could have h3
and we could play bishop h2 but now we
lose our only prized possession our
bishop
andrea i don't care about the [ __ ]
okay we got camp and we move
that's cold i might say that it's
um high time for a night move
i wouldn't necessarily agree but it's
okay
i thought you're a magician magnus weave
it into gold wear out the gold
i would have loved to see g5 there
actually
what if we get a little crazy magnus you
can't you can't talk about crazy on
every single move
not every single move it's going to be
crazy
start uh tell me we're going to get a
little bit
solid on the next move all right solid
let's get started then
no keep it
you have to remember he's a content
creator and if it's not crazy it's not
click baity
i will say you know the the most fun
played format i have is
bullet one minute
where you don't get to play chess at my
level it's where you just move pieces
as fast you can so what did i just say a
few moves ago
say solid let's make a king move oh
it's actually referring to the thing i
said before that but it is okay
uh magnus who picks up your hints better
ludwig andrea
so far but it's it's getting closer
don't worry by the end of the match uh
you know what let's go with the pawn
move here yes
keep it simple
i think we need to go with the rook move
okay queen
yes maybe now pawn move yes
there we go so what happened here is
that they put
they put their knight really really far
away from the king
so it makes a lot of sense for us to
open up on that side
and that they're quick knight f3 yeah
knight f3 would have been would have
been much better
we'll just create a good lexicon of
coughing and sneezing
[Laughter]
which file number all right
do you know any swedish words by the way
ludwig
oh yeah uh very few i know um
we need to create some clock
var for which is uh
just random words i'm not i'm not sure i
can use any of these things to cheat
sure we'll work on it
maybe a pond move yes you love to see it
just kick him away
yeah any opportunity for them to blunder
as we said
i would just like to make a king move
here yes
yes that's by far the best move go for
it
go for it an obvious obvious thing there
because yes okay
that's a good move they're fighting back
thank you
many times when i say you don't hear me
so if you could fix it okay
wait wait a sec wait a second just for
one sec we have a brilliant way to win
now
oh a brilliant way to win yes ah
okay okay so you want me to have a
you know what i'll allow this i'll allow
this but if we beat magnus we change his
profile photo for a day
yeah yeah magnus put it on the line
put something on the line if you're
gonna be suspicious sure if you win
if you win this game it could be
cause so it's it's obviously not the
bishop here or excuse me the uh the
queen here
no more hints magnus because i said
queen and then you said
brilliant how does this follow is this a
win
no more hints magnus i would keep it
simple stupid i would double the queen
on the rook file that's what i was
thinking but then
it feels like that wasn't what you were
thinking we could also maybe do this
move i don't know what that does for me
how about we make a how about we make a
how about we make a rook move
shut up shut up girlfriends
he's gonna see his own tactic what do
you mean he knows it
this is still this is still not over
we're still we can still change his
profile photo it's not over it's just
we have to win okay so
[Applause]
uh let's make a bishop move yes
tonight rook rook
let's make
just a simple pawn move
magnus new profile photo incoming
okay no not necessarily yeah
they're still fine kind of let's do no
i'm pretty sure
let's do queen
i would also like to do queen oh thank
god
something is so bad i'm so bad i'm so
bad
oh my god we got his profile picture
we got it it's not over yet it's the
best of five ever
on this game on this game we made a one
game bet
[Laughter]
it doesn't even matter if we lose the
match anymore we got five
brother maybe he could change it to
borat for a day
you know something mild okay sure
so walk me through this brilliant vision
because i just knew you wanted something
custom so i just said rook
but i had no idea why they couldn't take
okay so if they take
we're gonna go with queen h7 if they go
queen g3
we have mate in one with queen h4
okay i'm sorry what move are you
suggesting instead of
they go back to g1 g1 then we played g3
so you had the right idea there uh and
e3
basically our uh
our uh idea of queen h2 is unstoppable
so they would have to move both their
queen and their rook
in order to get in an escape square for
the
uh for the king and they can't do
uh both things at once
and it very fittingly says here on the
server
looks like that game slipped through
your fingers
nurses all right all right all right we
have to make a comeback of sorts
uh because it is the best of five give
me a moment at the piss and then we'll
win
yeah i'll take a p break too
wait magnus what line were you talking
about
no so knight d3 rook h2 so if you take
on h2
then queen h7 knight
knight d3 rook h2 if you take on h2 then
there that was just explaining the mate
there oh
okay okay okay if we took on h2 got it
got it got it okay okay